your two options stay patient or quit
which one's more attractive George I'm
mommy title
not a crack daddy come back neither like
a visible and I see with clarity husband
like my name is Gary Sabah [ __ ]
I've been telling you
Allison talk about yeah I'm triple-a
camera pedigree to meet and a pleasure
my faculties are putting the works and
i'm gern are the moving furniture
you guys this quick haul but I wanted to
read something at having I think there's
so much growth for me on Instagram and
I'm concerned that people getting
confused I don't think I'm worth
listening to or being paid attention to
because I have funny quotes or inspiring
quotes or inspiring one minute clips on
Instagram not what I'm saying I'm doing
[Music]
the garage would be if I had to use
Narada and Sedona 105 a seven coming a
mouse and a BMP pertain to run in front
of my house the reason swaggity to drive
by the rules of the life and what I keep
its my heart and what a dick it is now
and nothing would come of this store
crazy instead of glad the deterrence to
have a secret 50/50 drunken ass make me
drops man the [ __ ] gotta go haven't
seen a sense what or not for the trades
when the watching you crazy
oh in your music man [ __ ] join a
hospitable I will give in the backward I
like both pro and con please people to
confuse like obviously I communicate on
the human being but this is not what I'm
[ __ ] doing 18 hours a day not what
I'm posting three times a day on
Instagram
the executions come on YouTube live
activity alive but I'm not really loud
try and says I'm live but I'm not you
guys hear me welcomes Iraq yeah
alright guys I want to figure out how to
get a better connection I will
definitely be back on this we will
definitely do this life will happen a
comical together because I'm not magic
or special anything in how clever my
picture is on Instagram I'm trying to be
special on the fact that I'm out
executing strategically and then putting
in the actual work just to build
businesses that come from merit in a
good place and bring enormous value to
the people within them and the people
that watch how it's done so that they
can map it and do it themselves I don't
think I should have any guess when a
scary anymore will just get upset that I
interrupted on and I think they're right
I'm just not going to do they say fine
if you're anything perfectly I'm just
gonna [ __ ] them yeah I'm not gonna like
the funniest part is I don't do anything
for it I do a couple things
solid so do what I did really good I
thought you know Tony Coutu like
everybody can just loading tend to like
the duel one I really tried I really
tried on Tony tell me how to go and so
like I want to move it a lot like it's
how my brain works like by the way it's
like there's plenty people that you know
me that love it because they don't like
listening to podcast that's like we let
the person answer for 700 years
everybody oh the [ __ ] they're saying
sorry I don't get people it's like
people are very sad I don't like
I just actually know what that's it I'm
only doing guests and you know I'm kind
of triple down I'm not going to try
anymore to be so on
you think I'm interrupting now wait to
[ __ ] episodes 300 [ __ ] will
have 15 of the most people you ever saw
I got there nothing work so this is
about my [ __ ] post somebody execution
I don't want to see you look I know my
auto fix it a used and any loose no we
want to have green funny Holly mean we
need to need to create content of this
forget it's not super complicated you
known as a it's just [ __ ] that's it
you now take the airport like it's bad
that I'm so closing in there for the
feels like home what we have we have
Naples we have Atlanta if st. Louis we
have office for the Bjork name it became
too persistent went up those on your
lawn ready to go
[Music]
all right probably give this like every
single hour all right and it's probably
really cool really cool for me looking
like just drawings right
what's your name a Liam please read you
explain hello Bradley you mind if I get
freaking out no problem
thank you very much like a real pleasure
thanks my man far Thank You Bella my mum
resistive made everything so persistent
when I look around you're all ready to
go I don't wanna I don't want to see you
in my vanity I don't want to see you
walking on my ice we said these out here
in Florida pretty up at God dinner done
tonight proud ease here you are but you
already know that because I'm sure
you'll show that goofy thing he did
[Music]
I'm pretty at night a lot of business
development pretty senior stuff to be
really cool Friday really looking
forward to it this Friday South by
Southwest my 10th anniversary of going
to that conference the place where a lot
of this happened
learn that a lot of the people that
change the course of my professional
career really got into the web 2.0
movement giving the cue a keynote so
instead of pontificating just rolling in
saying comments you know my spiel fire
away with your questions really looking
forward to it should be a lot of fun and
we'll see what comes of it really a not
sure what's going to happen in
counterpunch I'm sure it's the same old
stuff right people looking for
permission to go people looking for that
extra push that extra motivation some
people looking for that subtle detail
that secret here's a secret score
letters wo RK that's the [ __ ] secret
and will always be the secret the only
thing you can control your talent is
your talent you can only maximize it and
so it should be fun really looking
forward to a bio a good mix of like
corporate fortune 500 people
entrepreneurs startup hardcore tech
founders media journalists real
hodgepodge real kind of cool melting pot
of different people with different
agendas different strategies so looking
forward to it you know for all of you
that are going to South by Southwest my
one tip is to just say hello right the
conference's are about networking the
content you can watch the next day or
follow the Twitter stream right but
saying hello and and sparking up a
relationship is something that's not
what replicatable
genuinely maybe the only time you ever
get to do it so whether somebody you
admire or you're standing in line and
you don't know the person you never know
if that person is the key to your to
your next step I think a lot of people
think information is the unlock to the
next chapters in their career but I find
that it's the people that are often the
actual unlock and so really easy tactic
say hello up these the warm and kind and
network I know something loving the idea
is that or the Samantha I'm empathetic
to that that I would highly recommend
trying to break it if you're going to a
conference looks out by the networking
is the RLI good afternoon
Instagram how are you hope you're well
you'll care for that and this drop
please be patient when building a brand
I realize in George there's no choice
patients and patient's of the only
option but you have two options stay
patient or quit which was more
attractive George what up ray Franklin
do this for you what do you think about
Brenda Marshall not being a gentle fad
Brenda friend is a really good player
but the just need to rebuild we need to
go 16 like you know
whereas cooking fuel APL as well ETL
tomorrow
Lana tomorrow tomorrow night New York
then st. Louis then Boston there's no
more udemy courses we did that for a
book promotion I'm just putting out
content the only male udemy courses
watch daily be watch what I do
don't listen to what I say watch what I
do when I say what should I do
delicious what I said
[Music]
watch what I do there's all sorts of
versions the common one is Airport Gary
the rare one is business attire Gary but
a pretty pretty big meeting for us
tonight very vocal for the strategy of
the agency and so I'm excited it's going
up once in a while Xerox you're
impressed right it's rare not to shout
it anyway go ahead
rare limited edition too scary anyway
keep hustling everybody we have a great
day
talk to you soon and actually you know
what this is not the end of it we're
going to do some live tonight back at
the crib see we'll get a little more
footage
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]